[Musique]
ce que nous verrons pas les quelques 100
millions de téléspectateurs qui à
travers le monde suivent la chasse au
trésor cela pourrait s'appeler les
coulisses de l'exploit
un exploit qui se renouvelle chaque
semaine dans un pays différent
aujourd'hui c'est la calédonie qui a été
choisi une publicité inespérée pour le
territoire
9h30 à magenta philippe de dieuleveult
s'apprête à partir pour le mans kogi
c'est là que commencera l'émission trois
trésors seront à trouver mais
l'animateur n'est pas dans le secret ils
sont d'ailleurs très peu nombreux à être
au courant c'est luc chevalerie qui a
préparé d'énigmes et qui a été le
conseiller tout au long de la
préparation de cette émission
préparation qui a duré quatre mois n'est
rien n'a été laissé au hasard par le
producteur même la coutume si l'équipe
revenait à se poser en tribu avec
philippe de dieuleveult à cameramen dont
la tâche n'est pas facile
un technicien hélicoptère a été aménagée
spécialement pour l'émission tout au
long de son déroulement
un cessna survolera l'appareil ils
servent de relais radio entre l'éthique
portage et le poste de commandement
installé autour de grands dommages à
l'hélicoptère de la gendarmerie est
aussi grand coup il emmène avec lui une
moto qui pourrait être portée utile à
philippe de dieuleveult
lorsqu'il sera quelque part dans la
chaîne
la première énigme a trait à la mine de
carola philippe de dieuleveult doit
retrouver le pic l'un pionnier il n'a
pas d'autre indication il comme le
survol la tribu de saint louis
il décide de s'imposer pour demander à
quelqu'un de l'aider nous sommes ici en
pleine émission et il n'est pas possible
à notre reporter d'image de s'approcher
afin de ne pas perturber le déroulement
[Musique]
le chef de la tribu accepte de servir de
guide des monte à bord de l'hélicoptère
[Applaudissements]
à vingt mille kilomètres de là dans un
studio l'antenne de à paris deux
candidats de nationalité suisse dialogue
en direct à 2100 voir les images
les images qui seront calées plus tard à
paris
là bas il est minuit trente et le
cerveau se trouve dans la tour de
contrôle de magenta le producteur est en
hausse constante avec harry l'équipe sur
le terrain du csna les candidats n'ont
su que quelques minutes avant l'émission
que la calédonie on serait le thème mais
ils seront bien des difficultés et nous
trouverons le crosnier trésor qu'après
seulement 22 minutes
il restera à peu de temps pour la
recherche des deux autres essais de
justesse qui découvriront la deuxième
énigme à bord d'une épave
attention c'est une folle aventure
pendant une heure donc on est tous
tendus pendant une heure on donne le
maximum c'est l'aboutissement de quatre
mois de travail de quatre mois de
négociations pas toujours facile tout
est arrivé à être prêts au jour j voilà
moment à la minute prévue
et puis c'est la magie du direct car on
travaille en direct
il n'y a pas de montage cette émission
dure une heure et elles surgissent
pendant une heure alors ben un peu déçu
quand même parce qu'on avait deux
candidats j'aime beaucoup la suisse est
un pays merveilleux
on n'a pas eu de chance on a eu des
candidats qu'ils n'étaient peut-être pas
dans le coup faut expliquer que l'été
est minuit et demi quand on a commencé
cette émission ici en nouvelle calédonie
était minuit et demi à paris les
candidats devaient peut-être fatigués
ils avaient peut-être voyager en train
je ne sais pas pour revenir enfin bref
il n'était pas dans le coup ils ont mis
beaucoup trop de temps à réagir et le
chevalier qui a préparé cette émission
avec moi je crois qu'il était volé aussi
déçu que moi on avait tellement envie de
montrer ce joyau il nous a tellement
vendu la nouvelle calédonie on est
tellement devenu amoureux la nouvelle
calédonie bac on est un petit peu déçu
parce que ce que je fais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui peut le faire bon ben j'ai
été choisi pour le faire attendre pour
mieux très bien attendu pour moi mais il
ya beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes qui
peuvent qui peut faire ça je fais aucun
problème va se dérouler la prochaine
chasse aux trésors nathan d'antan et moi
nous repartons sur sur paris et puis fin
janvier on va prendre un petit peu de
repos pour les fêtes
fin janvier et bien nous allons en
sicile au maroc en espagne et puis après
les partons à cuba et aux états unis
cette émission deviennent de plus en
plus une grande aventure c'est un c'est
plus un quiz kong en amérique c'est un
game show un grand spectacle c'est
l'idée de jacques antoine c'est de faire
maintenant des jeux non plus faire des
petits jeux comme les j'aime beaucoup
les chiffres et lettres
mais c'est un petit jeu la chasse au
trésor c'est un spectacle la culture et
du spectacle
or là les candidats nous ont remis dans
le cadre d'un petit jeu b bête et
stupide et c'est dommage parce que
philippe avait envie de donner l'énergie
qu'il a dans le ventre et et il a été
[ __ ] par des gens qui ne sont pas des
show men
[Musique]